- I'm excited to try on her dress.
I never really thought
that I would ever wear it.
- You know what, I really
don't know what to expect.
- I'm probably not going to get emotional.
Sorry about that!
- No, it's okay!
- I might cry.
But I might not.
- Oh God!
- I'm definitely gonna cry.
- It was a nice dress for $25.
- It'd be like a $40 dress today, right?
- My mother in law wore it in 1952,
and then I wore it in 1987.
And so, this'll be the third time
it's been put on by
somebody in our family.
- This dress was meant to be a symbol
of dreams and hopes and
what I wanted for my life.
- [Blonde Girl] So Mother, turn around.
- Okay, you can turn around now.
- Turn around Mama.
- (gasps) Oh my God!
- [Daughter] (laughs) Mama...
I look like you.
- (laughs) The sleeves!
- Your arms are longer than mine.
- Well, I think you look great.
- I feel like Keira Knightley.
In a good way!
There is nothing bad, ever,
about feeling like Keira Knightley.
I just feel like this
looks like the nightgown
of a queen in the 1700's.
- Obviously, it doesn't fit
so I couldn't wear it.
I could just go like this right now
and just bust the whole thing open.
I do think it's really pretty.
- Oh, Mom.
I used to idolize my mom when I was a kid
and I just remember
her looking so gorgeous
like a Barbie, so it's really
interesting to be in this.
I never thought that I'd wear it.
- I think it's a really nice dress.
- It is a really nice dress.
- There wasn't a Lifetime
movie moment here,
no one cried.
- No, no one cried.
- So when are you gonna get married?
- (laughs) Nice try, Mom.
(laughs)
- It was very emotional for me
just to think that she
might try on my dress
and it was just nerve-wracking to think
of this step in her life.
- Oh, Oh my God!
- Mom!
- If it would have fit me perfectly
I think it might have been
a different experience,
like, "Oh, I could see myself
walking down the aisle!"
But this is more like I'm playing dress up
when I'm ten years old, or something.
- I expect to see you in a dress like this
maybe when I'm in a nursing home.
- That's upsetting.
- I don't think that's a question!
(laughs)
- I think that you wear it best.
- Yeah?
- You do, yeah.
- I actually think you did,
'cause I think that the hat makes it.
- Oh, my mom totally wore it better.
My mom, for sure.
- No...
- She is so gorgeous.
- She totally wore it.
- No, I think she did.
- [Mom] When I saw you with the veil on,
it was actually kind of funny!
(laughs)
- [Daughter] Oh yeah, the
veil made me look like the
- [Both] Bride of Frankenstein!
- That's what I thought
when I first saw you
but I didn't want to say that
because I didn't want to offend you,
but yeah.